John Oliver is of course right at the
top of YouTube trends right right on
time
with a video where he now hates Border
Patrol a couple of things really quickly
John Oliver I think is absolutely
hysterical but this video it took a
while to wade through because it's
really only making two arguments and it
uses a lot of logical fallacies and
self-admittedly outdated data to make
these points but people are forwarding
it around as though it's it's it's a
valid argument against Border Patrol so
let's go to this first claim the first
claim is really and this is that the
fulcrum of video that border patrol is
corrupt inordinate inviolate and thus
boosting numbers of border control
agents would be ineffective instead of
going through each clip there's so much
of this it's recurring let's let's show
the montage as they doubled in size
meeting and maintaining their hiring
quotas meant that they're screening
process wasn't always as strong as it
could have been over half of CPP's
applicants were found unsuitable for
service as the ranks grew corrupt this
is important we'll come back to if 77
agents were arrested or indicted for
corruption so it's less one bad apple
than oh my god that is a lot of bad
apples and it gets even worse because
remember these agents have guns and it
is worth pointing out that a reported 25
yards where Border Patrol agents shot
people who thrown rocks concluded that
too many cases do not appear to meet the
test of objective reasonableness with
regard to the use of deadly force
okay so before we move on to what those
numbers he presented actually are in
context John Oliver admits later on a
video that his entire argument here is
mostly been based on us from men as he
says there have been implementations use
of force rules have been put in place
there have been tightening on hiring
requirements but he skims over it and
again this is the crux of the whole
video and in about 30 seconds where he
mentions his data might be out of date
in recent years they've improved hiring
and made reforms for instance they've
slightly increased transparency and
given agents more non-lethal weapons
like pepper spray guns as well as
rewriting their use of force rule book 2
and I quote prohibits the shooting of
suspects fleeing the scene who do not
pose a threat to themselves or others
and it goes
to make some funny jokes again go watch
the whole video for context because I
think that's what's most important here
he uses a lot of studies in data from
before 2013 or some before 2012 well
here's what's important policies like
the customs that they're publishing
public reports on use of force incidents
the use of firearms has dropped by 53%
since 2012 they've instituted a national
use of force board to review and correct
these instances in 2013 something that's
not included in a lot of his data a
nationwide training initiative to curb
alcohol abuse was used so again he can
say well some of this has changed no all
of it has changed okay all of it is
different now second if we go to the
original stats that he presented context
is more important than content because
it's nowhere near as bad as he tries to
claim so this is something that's really
important because leftist often try to
take numbers out of context I'm not
saying throw out statistics not saying
throw out facts okay but you can throw
out a number and if there's no
understanding or context it's often used
to vilify somebody or set a narrative
that's not necessarily accurate so the
number he uses whenever he uses before
all the corrections mind you so let's go
to as bad as it ever was and it's mostly
been fixed 77 agents when we're talking
about corruption over a 12-year period
equals about 6 agents per year out of
21,000 that's somewhere around point
zero zero zero three percent of agents
get indicted on a yearly basis so again
leftist love to provide these numbers
without context inevitably to make law
enforcement look bad we kind of see that
with the Algiers Motel incident yeah the
film was called Detroit motel it starts
talking about Detroit and riots but
let's ignore 1962 this very second
someone say the entire context of the
show exactly so they ignore the content
like this study at Washington Post same
kind of study that John Oliver cites so
eleven hundred arrests per year okay
looks bad the context when you run those
numbers against the average population
that the normal populace we can see the
same study demonstrates oh one point
seven arrests per 100,000 it was police
officers with people and law enforcement
were the general arrest rate in 2012
alone was 3888 per 100,000 for those who
can't do the math
1.72 3888 it's like thousands more he
makes one other claim which I just it's
not the main claim of this video but the
irony is so rich you'll get gout and the
problems didn't stop once the new agents
were hired because the training was also
significantly cut back and that caused
real issues the source told us Spanish
language classes and physical training
were cut back the person was so out of
shape I actually had a treat to trainee
and the bad guy got away pretty much
everybody gets through the Academy they
cut back on Spanish and physical
training cut back on physical training
we're complaining about that now hold on
a second
it is the social justice left who want
diversity mandatory recruitment memo
they want women in the military you have
consistently driven down training
requirements whoops in the name of
tolerance and diversity you hold on a
second didn't we just have a debate over
the fact that leftists wants
transgenders to go into the military
without any kind of additional screening
with a 42% attempted suicide rated and
now you're gonna take the moral high
ground on jogging that's pre military
there's a big logical fallacy throughout
this video if you haven't noticed it and
that's there are problems with the
Border Patrol therefore we shouldn't
hire more agents so that this is
something that John Oliver does a lot
there this therefore that okay we have a
border so if we have an illegal
immigration problem or a crime wave
problem that doesn't change that there's
a problem with maybe some corrupt police
which as we said is not nearly as severe
as he argues they're two separate issues
you can have imperfect border control
you can have immigration problems which
need to be solved and they could still
actually be partially solved by hiring
more Border Patrol agents even though
they are imperfect while we're
simultaneously improving them doesn't
mean because Border Patrol agents don't
work all the time that we don't need
more of them that's why Barack Obama
himself bragged that he had more Border
Patrol agents than any president in
history just because they're not the
they're not perfect in all facets
doesn't mean that having more Border
Patrol agents doesn't help at the border
so let's let's wrap this up here because
this is important to the overall context
of the video and people will miss this
and yeah something's bothering me about
that guy but I can't quite put my finger
on okay this is just the border control
but John Oliver we know doesn't want a
wall he thinks that silly we see this
now he doesn't want any kind of Border
Patrol he thinks that silly he supports
sanctuary cities because he thinks it's
silly not to have them doesn't want
voter ID doesn't want Social Security ID
doesn't believe that you should have
firearms to protect yourself from any of
these people and by the way he wants
health care for all whether you have ID
are here legally or not while we're
taking away the border wall and border
control oh and by the way all of this is
supported from old data and logical
fallacies to push some kind of a
tolerant agenda and this is why everyone
is waking up to the fact I think we set
with a Google letter where it's
unbelievably polite it's unbelievably
well written in people values we see
that here the left has gone so far
around the bend they want you to live in
a world with no country with no borders
no ability to secure itself and you have
to pay for everybody regardless of level
of contribution this is why people are
realizing there is no common ground and
the ultimate goal of today's left it
cannot be achieved without the complete
destruction of Western civilization it
can't exist with the totality of what
they're looking to do John Oliver
stances in the DNC in today's social
leftist agenda it can only work if the
United States ceases to be and more and
more people are waking up to it if you
like this video subscribe by clicking
the button that says subscribe if not
there's a strong chance that you're an
armenian genocide denier wink wink i
think you know what i'm talking about
but i don't over there this isn't the
channel for you i'm sure you'll find
something there that you deem very
insightful and informative also i
request that you come back here
afterward and immediately leave a
negative comment because we read those
and those affect our lives directly we
care about them because we care about
you